what's going on guys the Martian landed
in theaters and it's number one at the
box office
audiences loved it but as the science
holdup today we brought in a couple of
actual scientists to let us know about
the movie science of the Martian and one
thing you may notice is that I'm not
wearing a spacesuit
I'm just we're in a regular fancy suit
this is to support made man's formal
Friday initiative to help men in need to
learn more about it stick around to the
end of the video or click on the link in
the description below and now the movie
science of the Martian once again
gracing us with his presence dr.
Clifford V Johnson you are a doctor of
physics I'm thrilled to be joined by
Christina Heinlein and you are a
planetary geologist and you've been
published for original research on Mars
that's right how I did a thing on Phila
silicates on Mars first of all did you
like the movie yes very much
yeah I thought the movie was really
entertaining it brings up some really
good topics if we ever decide to go to
Mars did this film the Martian feel more
like science fiction or science
nonfiction I feel like it was more
nonfiction anything to do with science
usually they speed it up they they they
leave out that very important slow
processes of stopping thinking and
figuring something out it was
essentially a movie celebrating problem
solving which is what science and
engineering is all about how did Matt
Damon stay in such a good mood the whole
time yeah it's a really great question
getting lonely and feelings you know the
solitude of space could be very
detrimental to the psyche of any person
he was in a pretty decent mood most of
the time for being stranded alone how
many miles away from Earth oh gosh
between say 7 and 20 light minutes
that's a light minute how far light
travels in a minute so 3 times 10 to the
8 meters per second is roughly the speed
of light and then you can convert that
how you like okay meters like a yard I
still don't know how fast it goes okay
Mars in general did you feel that that
was an accurate portrayal of the planet
we use Arizona as an allegory to what
Mars
and so that's basically what they did in
this film - it is very close there are
some differences the sand on Mars does
not like say it here but you'd scoop it
up so in the storm for example where
they have those big pieces flying around
or whatever it would have been more like
little sharp pieces of razor sharp glass
flying through the air it would have
been painful but probably not portrayed
exactly the same he grew a potato crop
yeah did that make sense to you I think
it made some sense so in the very
beginning of the film one of the first
things they say is I found soil and he
goes oh great you found dirt good for
you so they start the film with I found
something thick enough under you know
the top layer that is gonna be something
useful for soil so he could possibly
find out on Mars that's not impossible
they were very careful to show us that
he needed certain kinds of things the
fact that he had a supply of you know it
was an unfortunate source Oh what was
the source bacteria and things that
actually can help enrich the soil
what was the are the human waste the
human waste what's a euphemism for that
polite politely or impolitely even
politely well here the lot of bags are
it's very helpful
what's the gravity like on Mars the
gravity is a third of it of what it is
here so you would weigh one third of
whatever you weigh you weighed 90 pounds
you ate 30 pounds on Mars I weigh more
than 90 pounds nah Mars has a very thin
atmosphere yes and now we come to the
big problem ah the storm yeah I'm sort
of on the fence about the storm I think
it should have been it was a really big
storm with big chunks of things flying
around I just don't think that's what it
would look like so when he got hit by
that flying debris he was left when we
found him his suit was punctured yeah
was that portrayal accurate let's just
face it Matt Damon it would be dead
multiple multiple times okay no wow this
is the die heart of space film he
stabbed he gets frozen he gets exploded
where was Hans Gruber exactly he
converted fuel to water is that correct
well he extracted the hydrogen from
fuel yeah so that he could then burn it
with oxygen to produce water that's you
know totally possible it's something we
can do in the lab we're in a drought why
don't we set up a factory to just make
water like that well the sort of
quantities he needed is very different
from those little quantities we need so
that would be my first time so we
probably need a couple gallons more yeah
a tad more but they just discovered
water on Mars why didn't he go to the
creek those creeks are not really creeks
the point is is that my grandma I used
to go down to the creek on Mars
oh no let's talk about JPL for a moment
they've worked at JPL I did I worked
three years what did you think of the
portrayal of the scientists the nerdier
that they look is the more accurate I
sort of got my first day there they made
me sign Robert a Heinlein books just
because my last name was Heinlein I had
a lot of fun with the various kinds of
portrayals for example it wasn't all the
one kind of scientist right usually you
in these depictions you have they're
either all socially awkward nerds yeah
all they're all you know scientists
superheroes or what have you
this was a mixture as is true in the
real world and the whole Lord of the
Rings naming of the thing that is a
thousand percent accurate are you
kidding me they love it let's talk about
the rescue sequence they got all the
weight out of that capsule and he
blasted out towards the rescue ship was
that accurate the trajectory he manages
to me with his puncturing his hole in
his hand he's lying around an Iron Man
right I just felt the sort of the Iron
Man thing was a little silly yeah yeah I
never saw anything like that near days
any kind of Harebrained Schemes one of
my specific jobs was to give a danger
rating for each of the landing site
selection options for inspiration that's
currently on there Wow if there was a
danger rating of five percent the answer
was we're never going there we're not
I'm going to try to land there so let's
give this a guess on the percentage of
success for this trip yeah I'm gonna
give it a 99.9% chance that it would not
be successful well us
no thank you you're for
in one important detail right got to
bring our boy home we got to bring our
boy No Child Left Behind no I should I
love this no astronaut left behind
she blew up half the ship in order to
propel them towards him oh yes right yes
Jessica Chastain Michael Payne yet as
they sort of exercising propulsion yes
you need a very controlled explosion
explosion to sort of point that properly
so I uh you know I don't know how much
control they really had they just had a
thing blow up in the thing and I don't
know whether the shape of that shaft
helps point it in the right direction
say that phrase again shape of that
shaft okay yes yeah just moving on yeah
um Alice seems so crazy that like yeah
let's just blow up half the ship well
you've actually pointed out something
that's very a very interesting issue
which is that in the early days of
manned missions to Mars which this is
supposed to be we would not be sending
such a massive over SPECT ship oh right
that that's that's your sort of movie
type of all these different
compartments and things and certain
things giant what Headroom and they're
like raising they have a swimming pool
let's go watch the message on the flag
Valentine YZ oh that's only over the top
they're basically flying around in a
space mansion how come an interstellar
daemon can't connect and dock and he
blows himself up but in the Martian he
kills it and he's our most decorated
fake astronaut Matt Damon most decorated
fake after that yeah it's a good
question scientifically please rank the
following films from most scientific to
least scientific gravity interstellar
the Martian the Martian probably the
most gravity next and in just I the
least gravity not out of the realm of
possibility so I'll say probably most
scientifically accurate futuristically I
can't answer but for right now we'll
have to go the Martian and then
interstellar there is actually one more
major unrealistic thing about the film
yes Sean Bean is in it and he makes it
all the way to the end that totally
doesn't make any sense if you were to
find yourself in that position that mark
Watney found himself in what would you
do first of all you've got to sit down
and go how much food do I have how much
food do I need and that's the first
thing he did I would just take one for
the team I certainly would never have
allowed my teammates to jeopardize their
life and our entire mission just for
them to come back and get me you are a
part of something bigger when you are a
scientist you have to think of the
bigger picture before trying to make
water myself I probably look for water
but maybe there just wasn't any around
and so indeed I would then start doing a
little bit of physics and chemistry to
manufacture water it's the sensible
thing I'd go crazy and kill myself well
we sure science the doubt of that
episode what's your favorite movie that
takes place in outer space let us know
in the comments section below and the
coolest answer we are going to send you
a screen junkies t-shirt once again I am
wearing a suit today in support of made
man's formal Friday joining thousands of
people who are dressing up for a good
cause why don't you go formal with made
man and career gear on Friday October
9th helping men in need to get the
training gear and resources to get back
into the workforce posted a per picture
of you and your fancy duds on Instagram
or Twitter with hashtag formal Friday
and made man will donate $1 to create I
want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye